We have the latest numbers from last week's
new unemployment claims.
Three point eight million more people, additional
people have lost their jobs.
We've been tracking this weekly since the
start of Carone.
I mean, we always track it weekly, but we've
been looking at numbers this bad since the
start of the virus.
Some weeks the numbers have been as high as
six point eight million in one week losing
their jobs.
This is now a reduction in new claims, 3.8
million more people lost their jobs last week.
So in total, this is the terrible news.
Thirty million people have now lost their
jobs due to corrupt coronavirus.
To give you a little context for that number,
before this started, the workforce was believed
to be one hundred and fifty eight million
in the United States, 1 5 8 million.
Thirty million is about 19 percent.
19 percent of all working people have lost
their jobs in the United States in the last
six or seven weeks.
This is nightmarish.
These are numbers that are so outrageous that
eight weeks ago they would have been unimaginable
numbers.
The slightly OK news.
If we're looking for trends, right, like if
we really if we want to find something that's
slightly OK, news is it's not 6 million every
week.
It's been diminishing.
We add 6.6 million people lost their job.
Get 6.8, then 6.6, 5.2, then 4.4 and now 3.8.
So hopefully over the next four to six weeks,
we'll see the numbers of new claims continue
to diminish.
Eventually, hopefully we will see a net decrease
in the number of people who are not working.
But this is not going to be quick.
You know, Trump talks about this V-shaped
recovery that will be as quick or even quicker
than the decline.
Doesn't seem like it's going to be that way.
Many jobs that are being lost are permanent
job losses.
Many businesses are not going to reopen.
And what's also becoming completely clear
is that there hasn't been enough stimulus
from the government.
We're now well into month number two of this.
Some states are about.
I mean, here in Massachusetts, we're very
close to entering month number three.
And there are still people who have not gotten
their twelve hundred dollar checks.
And even when they get the twelve hundred,
it's not going to be enough.
This is going to be a big deal.
Remember that before this, half the country
couldn't even afford an unexpected four hundred
dollar expense.
That was before this.
Those numbers are going to go way, way up.
They're gonna get much more ugly as this continues.
We are going to need more stimulus.
I would like to also see infrastructure done.
And I'll talk next week about how much more
stimulus we are likely to need, as well as
what an infrastructure deal would look like.
And you know, the thing about Trump is everything
is always a crony capitalist hit job.
Even when, as I said earlier, Trump is using
a lot of the right tools here to deal with
this recession, which could become a depression
or maybe already is, but is not yet reflected
in all of the numbers.
Trump is often using the right tools, but
it's always done in the wrong way.
It's always done in a corrupt way, eliminating
oversight for the stimulus money.
The peopIe program, which saw huge swaths
of the funding, go directly to big businesses
and organizations that don't really need it.
Even organizations with large endowments and
a lot of small businesses getting zero, getting
absolutely zero.
So next week, we'll talk about what would
infrastructure look like, how much more stimulus
are we likely to need depending on how this
goes and related topics?
My question to you, you can get back to me
on Twitter at David Pakman is where do you
think unemployment will top out?
There are people saying 40 million worth 30
million now.
Some people say 40 million.
Others are saying it's going to be a full
fifty fifty five million like a third of the
workforce.
If this extends for another six to eight weeks
to this degree, let me know where you see
that tragic number.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
We've got a tremendously good program for
you today.